VIRTUALLY IDENTICAL TO THE ONE
THAT CARRIED THEM INTO SPACE.
>> YOU'VE BEEN DREAMING OF SPACE
YOUR WHOLE LIFE.
YOU SPENT SUMMERS ON YOUR GRAND
DAD'S RANCH IN SOUTH TEXAS.
I IMAGINE-LOOKING UP AT THE SKY
AND THE STARS.
>> >> YOU WILL WHAT DO YOU THINK
YOUR GRANDFATHER WOULD THINK
TODAY?
>> WE CALLED HIM POP.
HE WAS A GIGANTIC FIGURE IN OUR
LIVES.
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH HIM.
I THINK IF HE WERE HERE, HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE MOST PROUD,
MOST EXCITED OF ALL THE PEOPLE
PRESENT.
SO HE HAD THIS CURIOSITY ABOUT
HIM AND THIS WONDER.
WHEN WE KNEW HIM, HE WAS A
RANCHER.
BUT BEFORE THAT HE HAD DONE --
HE WORKED FOR DAR PA AT ONE
POINT AMONG OTHER THINGS.
HE HAD ALL THIS EXPLORATION IN
HIM.
>> HE MIGHT HAVE BEEN IN THE
VEHICLE WITH YOU.
>> HE WOULD HAVE.
IT WAS A LONG LINE OF PEOPLE
TRYING TO STOW AWAY IN THE
VEHICLE THIS MORNING, INCLUDING
OUR DAD.
>> WE HAD TO CHECK.
>> YOU CALLED THIS THE MOST --
YOU CALLED BLUE ORIGIN THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING YOU WILL DO IN
YOUR ENTIRE CAREER.
YOU BUILT AMAZON.
THAT'S PRETTY HUGE.
YOU EMPLOY HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE.
HOW COULD BLUE ORIGIN BE BIGGER
OR MORE IMPORTANT?
>> YEAH.
ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT THIS IS,
YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO BUILT A
ROAD TO SPACE.
I MEAN, BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE,
REUSABLE SPACE VEHICLES AND SO
ON, SO THAT THE NEXT GENERATIONS
CAN BUILD THE FUTURE.
>> YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU ALREADY HAD
IN PLACE WHEN YOU STARTED DOING
AMAZON.
YOU HAD THE POSTAL SERVICE.
>> EXACTLY.
WHEN I STARTED AMAZON, I WAS A
YOUNG GUY, 27, ALMOST 30 YEARS
AGO.
YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO BUILD A
PACKAGE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
IT EXISTED.
IT WAS CALLED THE POSTAL SERVICE
AND U.P.S. AND DEUTSCHE POST AND
SO ON THAT.
WOULD HAVE BEEN HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN CAPITAL
EXPENSE TO BUILD.
>> SO SOME SMART KID IN A DORM
ROOM RIGHT NOW HAS A DREAM FOR
SPACE THEY CAN'T DO IT?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
BUT IF WE CAN LAY THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE, THEN DO THAT
HARD WORK, THERE WILL BE A BUNCH
OF ENTREPRENEURS.
MAYBE THE YOUNG GUY, OLIVER, WHO
FLEW WITH US TODAY WILL BE ONE
OF THEM.
>> WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
WHAT DOES THIS ROAD LOOK LIKE?
YOU TALKED ABOUT HUMAN PRESENCE
ON THE MOON
>> YEAH.
>> OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, ELON
MUSK IS TALKING ABOUT MARS.
WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE?
>> THERE ARE A COUPLE THINGS.
ONE OF THE THINGS IS IT'S REALLY
ABOUT MOVING HEAVY INDUSTRY.
I KNOW THIS SOUNDS FANTASTICAL,
AND IT IS FANTASTICAL.
REMEMBER, IF YOU WENT BACK TO
THE KITTY HAWK ERA AND SHOWED
THEM A 787, THEY WOULD HAVE SAID
THAT'S FANTASTICAL.
WE HAVE TO MOVE POLLUTING
INDUSTRY OFF EARTH.
EARTH IS TOO SMALL.
>> COAL PLANTS?
>> WE'LL BEAM IT DOWN.
WHEN WE MAKE CHIPS AND
MICROCHIPS AND EVERYTHING ELSE,
ALL THAT DIRTY POLLUTING STUFF,
WE'LL MAKE IT IN SPACE AND DO
THOSE ACTIVITIES IN SPACE.
IT'LL BE MUCH BETTER.
THIS PLANET IS SO PRECIOUS.
WE THINK THE ATMOSPHERE IS BIG.
BUT REALLY, THE ATMOSPHERE IS
TINY.
IT'S THIS TINY LITTLE FRAGILE,
THIN LAYER.
WE ALL DEPEND UPON IT FOR OUR
LIVES.
AND WE GOT TO STOP POLLUTING IT.
SO THAT IS SOMETHING -- BUT THAT
CAN'T BE DONE TODAY.
IF YOU TRY TO MOVE HEAVY
INDUSTRY OFF EARTH TODAY, THAT'S
CRAZY.
>> WHAT IS THE TIME LINE?
>> DECADES.
IT WON'T BE DONE IN MY LIFETIME,
BUT WHAT WE CAN DO AND THE BLUE
ORIGIN TEAM CAN DO IS LAY THE
FOUNDATION FOR THAT WORK.
THAT'S WHAT WE MEAN WHEN WE SAY
BUILD A ROAD TO SPACE.
BECAUSE THEN THERE WILL BE OTHER
PEOPLE DRIVING ON THAT ROAD AND
THEY'LL DO MUCH GREATER THINGS
THAN WE WILL DO.
>> WHY DO YOU WANT TO HAVE
PEOPLE ON THE MOON?
>> THE MOON IS A GREAT PLACE FOR
RESOURCES.
IT'S CLOSE, WHICH IS A BIG
ADVANTAGE.
SO ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS ABOUT
THE MOON IS IT HAS A VERY LOW
GRAVITY, 1/6 GRAVITY.
IT TAKES 26 TIMES LESS ENERGY TO
LIFT A POUND OFF THE MOON THAN
IT DOES THE EARTH.
SO IF YOU WANT TO BUILD BIG
STRUCTURES IN SPACE, YOU WANT TO
GO GET MATERIALS FROM THE MOON.
>> OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE STEPPED DOWN
AS CEO OF AMAZON.
YOU'LL HAVE A LITTLE MORE TIME
ON YOUR HANDS.
ARE YOU GOING TO FOCUS MORE ON
BLUE ORIGIN AND HOW MUCH MORE?
YOU'VE BEEN LIQUIDATING TO FUND
IT?
>> WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE.
I'M USING STOCK FOR THE BEZOS
EARTH FUND.
THE TWO BIG INITIATIVES I KNOW
OF RIGHT NOW ARE BLUE ORIGIN AND
BEZOS EARTH FUND, WHICH IS ALL
ABOUT SUSTAINABILITY, CLIMATE
CHANGE, PROTECTING THE NATURAL
WORLD.
WE HAVE TO WORK ON THE HERE AND
NOW OF THAT TOO.
BLUE ORIGIN IS WORKING ON THE
FUTURE, BUT WE HAVE TO WORK ON
THE HERE AND NOW AS WELL.
>> ELON MUSK TOLD "THE
WASHINGTON POST," YOUR
NEWSPAPER, THAT IF BLUE ORIGIN
IS TO BE SUCCESSFUL, YOU SHOULD
RUN IT FULL TIME AND HE HOPES
YOU DO THAT.
ANY CHANCE?
>> BOB SMITH IS THE COO OF BLUE
ORIGIN.
HE'S RUNNING IT AMAZINGLY WELL.
HE'S BEEN HERE ONLY A FEW YEARS
AND DOING A GREAT JOB.
I'M NOT TAKING BOB'S JOB.
BUT I AM GOING TO SPEND MORE
TIME ON IT.
I'LL HAVE THE TIME TO SPEND ON
IT.
SO I'M GOING TO BE ROLLING UP MY
SLEEVES DEEP IN IT.
>> DID YOU KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT?
INTELLECTUALLY YOU CAN KNOW
ABOUT SPACE FLIGHT AND
EXPERIENCE IT?
>> WE WENT THROUGH TWO AND A
HALF DAYS OF TRAINING.
WE WERE PREPARED FOR, YOU KNOW,
BASICALLY WHAT A NOMINAL MISSION
EXPERIENCE SHOULD BE LIKE, BUT
WATCHING A POWERPOINT AND VIDEOS
AND EXPERIENCING IT ARE VERY
DIFFERENT THINGS.
I WAS NOT PREPARED FOR WHAT THE
ACTUAL G FORCES FELT LIKE ON
LIFTOFF AND WHY WE WERE
ACCELERATING WHEN THE CAPSULE
SEPARATED FROM THE BOOSTER.
WE KNEW WHAT SOUND TO EXPECT,
BUT THAT SORT OF JUMP AS THE
SPRINGS RELEASED -- AND THEN,
YOU KNOW, JUST THE EXPERIENCING
ZERO G, YOU KNOW, IT WAS
REMARKABLE.
>> WHEN YOU WERE ALL SITTING IS
THERE TOGETHER BEFORE YOU
ENTERED THE CAPSULE, WHAT DID
YOU TALK ABOUT?
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
DANGER, A MILLION THINGS MUST BE
GOING AROUND IN YOUR MIND.
>> THEY KEPT ASKING WHAT'S
TAKING SO LONG.
THAT'S HOW YOU GET TO BE WALLY,
YOU'RE IMPATIENT IN A HEALTHY,
GREAT WAY.
SHE'S LIKE, THE LAST SIX-MINUTE
DELAY, WHY?
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE OUT THERE.
SO THAT WAS PART OF IT.
YOU KNOW, WE TOLD EACH OTHER WE
LOT OF EACH OTHER.
I MEAN, IT'S EMOTIONAL TOO.
THIS MORNING WHEN WE LEFT THE
HOUSE, LEFT WAY BEFORE THE CRACK
OF DOWN.
ALL OF OUR FAMILY WAS THERE AND
WE GAVE EACH OTHER BIG HUGS.
IT WAS AN EMOTIONAL MORNING.
>> IT WAS ALSO -- IT WAS A
MOMENT WHILE WE WERE ALL SITTING
ON THE LAUNCH PAD BEFORE WE TOOK
OFF AND JEFF SPOKE TO THE CREW.
HE'S LIKE, GUYS, BEFORE WE GO,
IF I COULD ASK YOU A FAVOR.
HE SAID WHAT WE'RE ABOUT TO DO
IS GOING TO BE EXTREMELY FUN AND
EXCITING.
HE GOES, BUT I WOULD ALSO
ENCOURAGE YOU, IF YOU WILL,
WHILE YOU'RE UP THERE, WHILE
YOU'RE TAKING IN THESE VIEWS TO
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT WHAT
WE'RE ABOUT TO DO IS.
AND HE WAS ABLE TO SAY, LOOK,
YOU KNOW, I KNOW WHAT SOMETHING
BIG LOOKS LIKE WHEN IT WAS
SMALL.
AND HE HAS THE CREDIBILITY WHEN
HE STARTED AMAZON.
>> YOU HAVE THE SAME IDEA ABOUT
BLUE ORIGIN?
>> THIS IS HOW SOMETHING BIG
STARTS, I KNOW WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE AND THIS FEELS EXACTLY THE
SAME.
>> IT'S A BEGINNING AND YOU CAN
FEEL.
>> IT TAKE IT IN.
>> BUT TO GET TO THE POINT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, YOU NEED A
TON MORE COMPANIES COMING UP
WITH NEW IDEAS, NEW WAYS TO
BUILD ROCKETS, EVERYTHING.
>> ANDERSON, THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
GREAT INDUSTRIES AND GREAT
CHANGE IS NOT EVER MADE BY A
SINGLE COMPANY.
IT'S MADE BY A WHOLE ECOSYSTEM
OF GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS AND
EVERYTHING ALL WORKING AS PART
OF AN ECOSYSTEM.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO -- THAT'S
WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN.
BUT THOSE FIRST STEPS, SOMETIMES
YOU CAN JUST FEEL, YOU KNOW, BIG
THINGS START SMALL, THEY ALWAYS
DO.
YOU CAN JUST TELL, WHAT WE DID
TODAY -- PEOPLE CAN SAY IT'S A
TOURISM MISSION, IT'S
SUBORBITAL, BUT IT'S AN
OPERATIONAL, COMMERCIAL VEHICLE
THAT WE CAN USE TO PRACTICE OVER
AND OVER AND OVER, TAKE PEOPLE
UP OVER AND OVER, AND GET REALLY
GOOD AT DOING SPACE TRAVEL.
AND IT IS LIKE THE BARN STORMING
DAYS.
THAT'S WHAT WHERE WE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW, AND THAT EVENTUALLY
LEADS TO THE 787.
>> THERE ARE A COUPLE
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS WHO
TWEETED OUT TODAY SAYING THIS IS
BASICALLY A BOONDOGGLE, IT'S A
WASTE OF MONEY, THERE'S MORE
IMPORTANT THINGS.
TO THAT, WHAT DO YOU SAY?
YOU GAVE AN ANSWER AND YOU GAVE
$200 MILLION AWAY TODAY, BUT
WHAT IS THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS?
>> WHAT I WOULD SAY IS U FIRST
AND FOREMOST, WE HAVE TO DO
BOTH.
SO WE HAVE TO -- FOR EXAMPLE, WE
HAVE LOTS OF PROBLEMS ON EARTH.
WE HAVE POVERTY, WE HAVE HUNGER,
ALL KINDS OF PROBLEMS, CLIMATE
DISASTERS, POLLUTION.
WE HAVE TO WORK ON THE HERE AND
NOW.
AND WE HAVE TO LOOK TO THE
FUTURE.
AND WE AS A SOCIETY, AS A
CIVILIZATION, AS HUMANITY, WE
HAVE ALWAYS DONE THAT.
WE HAVE NEVER JUST FOCUSED ON
THE PRESENT OR JUST FOCUSED ON
THE FUTURE.
>> WHAT HAPPENS IF WE DON'T DO
THIS EXPLORATION IN SPACE?
>> IF YOU DON'T FOCUS ON THE
FUTURE, YOU DON'T HAVE EXPLORERS
OR PROGRESS.
WHAT IF YOU SAID TO WILBUR
AND/ORVILLE WRIGHT, HEY, WHY
DON'T YOU WORK ON SOMETHING A
LITTLE MORE PRACTICAL?
YOU'RE SMART GUYS, CERTAINLY YOU
COULD DO SOMETHING MORE
PRACTICAL.
BUT THAT'S WHAT EXPLORATION IS.
IT'S A KIND OF WANDERING, AND
ALL SMALL THINGS HAVE THAT
CHARACTERISTIC THAT HERRERA NOT
OBVIOUS HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
WORK OUT, BUT THAT'S WHAT
EXPLORATION IS.
>> DO YOU HAVE "MOM" WRITTEN ON
YOUR HAND?
>> YES, WE DO.
IT'S ALMOST WASHED OFF NOW, BUT
WHEN WE WERE UP IN ZERO G,
YEAH -- BUT THAT'S BECAUSE I
FLIPPED UPSIDE DOWN.
WHEN WE WERE IN ZERO G.
THERE.
IT WAS LIKE THIS.
AND WE GOT THAT PHOTO.
>> WE WEREN'T SURE WE REHEARSED
IT A FEW TIMES.
>> REHEARSING THAT ON EARTH